take a look at this watch it's encased
in sapphire crystal
it has 60 different movements and
includes a dome that rotates in sync
with the lunar cycles
and it sells for more than 380 thousand
dollars
but even this isn't the most expensive
watch that money can buy
that's because watches like other types
of luxury goods are subject to a
little-known economic principle
that allows companies to charge sky-high
prices
these are called veblen goods and they
turn the usual equation of supply and
demand
on its head we'll explain
[Music]
let's start off with the more obvious
reasons why luxury watches command
such a high price number one the high
quality of materials
a luxury watch can have hundreds of
different parts and these can take
hundreds of hours to produce
and put together watches can be made
with materials like gold
silver and diamonds and inside
bearings that help keep time are made
with precise synthetic rubies
the material is a very important part
this is karen segetti
who has analyzed trends in the swiss
watch industry for over a decade
a steel or if you have gold or if you
have gold and diamonds
of course then already just the price of
the material is very
significant number two luxury watches
also take a high caliber of
craftsmanship to produce
for more complicated pieces with a
premium finish it can take months
or even years to make a single watch
most of the watches are swiss made
meaning that it's swiss watchmakers
working on the watch and you know the
that swiss labor is the most expensive
in the world
and the more time they spend on the
watch the more cost goes into it
but segetti says that while materials
and craftsmanship can be expensive
they make up only a fraction of the
overall price number three
the price of a luxury watch is largely
subject to what economists and marketing
experts
like eve hanania call perceived value
procedure user how a customer
would value what he buys there is a
segment out there
of men and women who would buy watches
which is an indication of their own
success or where they stand in life
this concept is pretty clear to raise
the price luxury watch companies
use marketing tactics to captivate
buyers brands like rolex
sponsor professional sports like car
racing and tennis
golden moment from wimbledon they also
tied promotions to high profile events
for example buzz aldrin wore the now
iconic omega speedmaster professional
when he became the second man to step
foot on the moon
the speedmaster professional is
certified by nasa for manned space
missions
which omega plays up in its branding
since 1995
james bond has worn an omega sea master
in every film
ah double 007 one last thing for you
does it do anything
it tells the time celebrity marketing
year can be an important
element to the perceived value because
if james bond
does wear that watch i can wear that
watch and i get me
a little closer to his lifestyle and his
power of seduction hanania explains that
this status symbol
is also seen as a long-term investment
there's
one very important element of perceived
value
is when you buy watch it's not like you
buy it for you
not only you see that investment but you
see there's a very emotional thing
to pass it on to your kids or even
grandkids
[Music]
but in the watch industry there's a
hidden economic factor
that drives price as well it's based on
the law of demand
which says that if the price of a good
goes down the demand for it will go
up you've seen this when products go on
sale
when a tv is discounted more people want
to buy it
but luxury watches appear to contradict
the law of demand
this is because they're classified as a
veblen good
named after the american economist
thorstein beblin
the veblen fx theory suggests that for
certain luxury goods
as the price increases so does the
demand marketing expert pinara yield jim
says that this is because expensive
veplin goods have the ability to show
off one's status
think of an item that helps you to
especially if you're interested in
signaling your wealth that helps you to
separate from others what's the most
effective way to do that
it's a it's a very high price right
because it's very difficult for others
to be able to pay the same price it's
very costly for others to to imitate you
that's why people are willing to pay
that extra price because it helps them
to really separate themselves from
others
and for many high-end watches there can
be an additional twist
the more expensive it is the more
exclusive it becomes
and the harder it is to attain the more
that people want to own it
this is called the snob effect it helps
explain why veblen goods carry a high
perception of value
which is why brands like richard meal
and patek philippe can charge
hundreds of thousands of dollars or more
for a single watch
and this is not just luxury watches it's
true for luxury cars it's true for
luxury handbags luxury shoes it's the
the items that help you signal
your status your belt but the veblend
and snob effects
only work up to a certain point this is
what's known as the sweet spot in
pricing
at a certain price even demand from
luxury buyers will start to decrease
if they feel that the higher price no
longer represents a higher level of
value
and there's another characteristic of
beveling goods that separates them
from normal goods as well when you cut
down on the price of a normal good
you will typically find higher numbers
of people who want to purchase that item
but this is not necessarily true for web
language if you
cut down on the price of a web language
you might actually find fewer number of
people
wanting to buy that item because it no
longer helps you to signal your wealth
as effectively as it did before
unlike some designer goods that do go on
sale veblen goods are items that are
priced to be more exclusive
and therefore more unattainable this is
why they're rarely discounted
it's the idea that the cheaper an item
is the less status
and therefore perceived value it holds
[Music]